[Music]
that is John Legend's new music video
preach legends call to action against
social injustice including racially
motivated traffic stops has been viewed
over 11 million times since it was
released just over two weeks ago
sometimes so stops have ended violently
and in an effort to curb racial
profiling North Carolina was the first
state to demand the collection and
release of traffic stop data a
University of North Carolina professor
took a look at the stats to find out
what it all means their fates were
forged on the side of a road volando
Castile Walter Scott Sandra bland all
were pulled over by police on a routine
traffic stop as a result all are dead
policing is unfair University of North
Carolina professor Frank Baumgartner
wrote a book on the subject what is the
purpose of our traffic laws the purpose
of our traffic laws should be to keep us
all safe but they have come to be used
as an excuse to do a police
investigation in suspect citizens
Bumgardner analyzes 22 million traffic
stops over 20 years in the Tar Heel
State he found that a driver's race
gender location and age all factored
into a police officers decision to pull
over a vehicle it made me realize that
people are not making stuff up the data
showed that african-americans have been
stopped twice as often as white drivers
and while they were four times more
likely to be searched they were actually
less likely to be issued a ticket
the study also highlighted that whites
who are more likely to be found with
contraband than blacks or Hispanics
there's a way that police interact with
middle class white Americans and there's
a way that people and the police forces
interact with members of minority
communities especially in poorer
neighborhoods you're viewed as a
criminal suspect I think there was some
resistance among law enforcement to
embrace the findings Chapel Hill Police
Chief Chris Bloo is a member
the North Carolina Association of Chiefs
a group that initially called the
preliminary findings deeply flawed
police officers go into this work for
noble reasons so when you see results
that suggest your work is having
disproportionate impacts that's hard to
stomach is it inherent bias I'm not sure
I know what it is police agencies are
trying to think very hard about what
policies and interventions they can put
in place that might help balance out
some of those disparities that were
found in the work the work that's been
done in North Carolina is a significant
from my perspective a significant public
service attorney Jim Johnson chaired the
committee to review New Jersey's police
standards after the 1998 shooting of two
black and two Hispanic men on the New
Jersey Turnpike lawyers and others
charged the state cops continue to use
racial profiling in deciding which cars
to stop they were unarmed
they were nevertheless they were shot
during the stop what were they stopped
for it was a routine traffic stop the
state agreed to settle with victims for
thirteen million dollars ultimately it
changed the way troopers conducted
police business
there was a consent decree and over the
course of about ten years the state
troopers worked with the community with
this Department of Justice to deal with
this issue and they dealt with it
by gathering data on all traffic stops
police discretion has been a power
backed by the US Supreme Court for
decades why do you think that is the
core it looks like me the Court has
ruled that we need to give the
discretion to our police officers and we
can trust them to use that discretion
appropriately nobody likes to be pulled
over by the police but it's not
traumatic but if your Foligno Casteel he
was pulled over I believe over 40 times
Castile was actually stopped 46 times
according to police records racking up a
total of six thousand dollars in fines a
sum his family has said he could neither
fight nor afford and when we look at
some of these in
actions they're trivial they're not
violent crimes it's not keeping us any
safety the quality of our work is
actually improved a 21-year veteran
chief Bleu is known as a police reformer
and is one of the first to implement
some of the report's recommendations
what have you changed
well we've de-emphasized an awful lot of
low-level kind of traffic enforcement
that the numbers clearly show have a
disproportionate effect on communities
of color has really had an impact on
your ability to fight crime no I don't
think so
in fact what we see is our officers are
still making traffic stops the quality
of their traffic stops has gone up the
number of unnecessary searches has gone
down the number of searches that result
in contraband actually being seized has
gone up for years
citations and arrests were a measure of
success the kind of analysis heated
around traffic stops showed us that what
we thought was effective policing was
maybe not achieving the things we
thought it would authorize Bob Gardner
hopes his analysis influences department
practices nationwide don't use the
traffic code to alienate people for no
good reason
only is the traffic code to go on a
fishing expedition to try to show who's
boss and when the minority community has
a significant voice in their local
government the police department doesn't
do this we can show that voting matters
voting matters and the fact that this
data get out there is proof of that you
know chief blue said something really
interesting to me he said you get behind
the wheel of a car you're gonna cut
you're gonna have an infraction you're
gonna violate the traffic code in some
way he says he tells his officers every
single day he says you better make sure
that the juice is worth the squeeze
there's a broken taillight worth it yeah
that was type of refraction yeah really
interesting to face facts about I like
what he said that what you're doing you
don't want to face the facts of what
you've been doing yep
hasn't been working yeah hard to stomach
again that came from 22 million the data
was 22 million traffic stop so there was
there was a lot of evidence